what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the tragic
and heroic life of the current number
two pro hero
keigo takami better known as the wing
hero
hawks after the manga finally revealed
the extremely dark truth about
hawks's traumatic childhood and how he
became the hero that he is today
i decided that i needed to dedicate a
full video to
this man if you enjoyed the boku no hero
videos
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going you know what to do leave a
quick like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you're new to anime
pro or maybe you watch our videos but
you still haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications before we get into it
a quick thank you to tapitune for
sponsoring this video tapitune publishes
the hottest korean web comics
in english french and german and they
feature some worldwide famous titles
like solo leveling what's wrong with
secretary kim
and a returner's magic should be special
and of course much more
they've got over 300 webtoons in many
genres
including action fantasy comedy and of
course
romance new titles and new chapters are
coming out
every week so you can binge them all and
never miss a new release
as a big fan of shonen solo leveling is
a great read for me
and i'm sure that a ton of you would
enjoy it as well if you haven't read it
already
and the latest action titles that are
getting a ton of hype are arriving to
tapitu
so check them out before everyone else
don't miss out on the likes of triple f
class trash hero or my 990 000 past
lives help me tapitune works directly
with the webcomic creators so every time
you use tapitune you are supporting the
creators of your favorite series
check out tapitune right now link in the
description
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been
warned when we first meet hawks in the
boku no hero story
he is only 22 years old and he is
already the number three pro hero
hawks is the youngest hero to ever crack
the top 10 list
and after allmight retires hawks
advances to the number two pro hero
position
i have to admit that at first glance i
thought that hawks was just some cocky
entitled kid who was lucky enough to be
born with a great quirk
i guess that's just how his public
persona came off to me at first glance
however the more we learned about hawks
the more i realized that my initial
impression of him was completely
off in chapter 299 of the manga we
finally learned more about hawks's
tragic backstory
and this is definitely a rough one it
turns out that hawks's father
was a hitman for heyer who was on the
run from the law
he lived in squalor outside the city
with hawks and hawks's mother
a woman by the name of tomie hawks's
father was constantly paranoid that the
police were going to find him and arrest
him for murder
so he forbade hawks and his mother to
leave the house
he was afraid that if they ever left the
house they could end up attracting
attention
and the police would come and get him so
if
hawks ever left the house he would be
brutally punished
by his father hawks's father was abusive
towards his son and his wife
and he would straight up say to hawks
that he never should have been born
on top of that hawks's mother seems like
she might have had some mental or
developmental issues
and so she was never able to fully be
there for hawks or to support
him in any way hawks's childhood was so
rough that when he saw heroes on tv
he just assumed that they must be
fictional clearly they must have been
part of some tv show or movie because
stuff like that doesn't happen
in real life definitely not to him in
his own life
hawks suffered through poverty and abuse
every single day
and no hero ever came to rescue him from
his cruel life
but then one day hawks's father was
caught by the police apparently he tried
to steal a car
but then he was stopped by endeavour and
sent to prison
it was in this moment that hawks
realized that
heroes were real they were not just
fictional characters on tv
they really did exist and one of them
endeavor
just rescued hawks from his father's
abuse by throwing his father
in jail because of this hawks gained a
true sense of appreciation for heroes
and especially for endeavor but this was
not
the end of hawks's troubled childhood
his mother was afraid that she would
also be arrested for helping his father
hide from the police for all those years
so instead of going to the police and
telling them the truth she took hawks
and they went
into hiding yet again but because
hawks's mother didn't really have any
real world skills
hawks and his mom ended up homeless and
living on the street
hawks's mom was frustrated by the
situation and she asked hawks why he has
wings in the first place if he can't use
them to make their lives better
his mother's words made an impact on
hawks and he decided to start using his
quirk in a way that is useful to society
he started performing heroic deeds even
as a kid
and after saving a bunch of people from
a car accident the young hawks caught
the attention of the hero public safety
commission
the commission offered to keep hawks and
his mother safe and to take care of them
financially
if they agreed to abandon the takami
name and accept
new identities soon after the public
safety commission decided to train hawks
to become a special
type of hero so they separated him from
his mother and subjected him to intense
training for many years
which explains why hawks managed to
accomplish so much
at such a young age he was forced to
completely abandon his former life
and dedicate his entire existence to
special hero
training hawks would eventually open his
own hero agency when he was only 18
years old
and he reached the top 10 pro heroes
list before he turned 20.
and as we know only a few years later
hawks climbed all the way up to the
number two spot
in the pro hero rankings right behind
the hero whom he admires the most
endeavor but if you thought that hawks's
hardship
ended when he was taken in by the hero
public safety commission if you thought
that
only his childhood was tragic and then
it was all uphill from there
sadly you would be mistaken the hero
public safety commission
is not what it appears to be on the
surface
and on multiple occasions hawks was
forced to do things on behalf of the
commission that he didn't necessarily
want to do he simply didn't have a
choice
in the matter one such order was hawks's
mission to become a double agent
and infiltrate the league of villains
hawks was forced to lead an extremely
dangerous double life as a villain who
was only pretending to be a hero
even though in reality he was a hero who
was only pretending to be a villain who
was pretending to be a hero
totally simple and not confusing at all
and not only did hawks risk his life
multiple times during his infiltration
of the league of villains
but he was eventually forced to kill
someone whom he didn't
want to kill i am of course talking
about twice
hawks believed that twice was a good
person at heart
and he tried desperately to convince
twice to do the right thing
and stop being a villain but after twice
refused to quit being a villain out of a
sense of loyalty to his legal villain
comrades
hawks was forced to kill twice in order
to prevent him from using sad man's
parade
against the heroes and the wider hero
society
basically twice was considered too
dangerous to be allowed to escape
so when twice did try to escape from
hawks hawks had to follow his orders and
end twice his life and not only was
hawks
emotionally scarred by this
confrontation with twice
a man whom he considered his friend but
he also suffered severe
burn injuries at the hands of dobby
during that same tragic showdown
so although it's been clear for a while
that there is something shady going on
with the hero public safety commission
the true nature of their organization is
not revealed
until much later in the story when we
meet lady nagant
lady nagant was taken in by the public
safety commission when she was just a
child
much like hawks and she was lied to and
brainwashed until she became the
commission's
designated killing machine from groups
plotting alleged terrorist attacks
to hero groups who are believed to have
been associated with villains
countless civilians of the hero society
were secretly assassinated by the public
safety commission without
ever being given a right to a fair trial
and while the most famous and beloved
pro heroes
worked in the light and made the hero
society look virtuous
state-sanctioned assassins like lady
nagant were working in the shadows to
keep any potential enemies of the hero
society
under control by any means necessary
lady nagant
soaked her hands in blood over and over
again while obeying orders from the
public safety commission
while pretending to be a wholesome hero
in public she was secretly being told to
kill
again and again at one point the
chairman of the hero public safety
commission
ordered lady nagant to eliminate two pro
heroes who were allegedly provoking
fellow civilians into committing crimes
so that they would then capture them as
criminals and claim rewards
this is of course a serious accusation
but it is just an accusation and yet
without presenting evidence against
these two heroes during a fair trial the
chairman of the public safety commission
simply
ordered an assassin to kill them because
that was more convenient
when lady nagant pushed back against
this order
she was threatened by the chairman and
that is when she finally
snapped she killed the chairman and went
on to become a villain
rather than a hero and so when lady
nagant learns that hawks
is her successor within the hero public
safety commission
she assumes that hawks must be just as
demoralized and
jaded as she is lady nagant knows that
as her successor hawks must have been
forced to do all sorts of horrible
things
by the hero public safety commission and
yet
she is shocked to see that hawks still
has that heroic fire
in his eyes she doesn't understand how
this is possible
how can hawks maintain a heroic spirit
after all the darkness that he must have
been through
how can he still want to be a hero after
realizing that the people who were
running the entire hero society were
actually villains themselves
but hawks just smiles at lady nagant and
says that
at the end of the day he is an optimist
on top of that he had someone who
supported him
which is a reference to endeavour and
the inspiration that hawks drew from
endeavour
ever since he was still a child this
brief exchange between lady nagant and
hawks her successor
tells us everything we need to know
about hawks as a person
and as a hero despite his extremely
tragic childhood
despite the fact that he was used by the
hero public safety commission
and despite all the physical and
emotional scars that he has suffered
in the service of the commission hawks
refuses to give up on his dream
of being a true hero and saving innocent
people just like deku and meteo hawks
is an idealist at heart and he truly
believes that heroes can change the
world
for the better but at the same time
hawks has been through a lot and his
hands have definitely been stained with
blood hawks is not a fair weather hero
like those heroes who decided to retire
after things got tough and he is also
not the kind of hero who naively thinks
that he can save
everyone don't get me wrong hawks does
his best to save as many people as
possible
but he is also prepared to do what has
to be done when saving the enemy
is not an option and that is exactly
what we saw with twice
hawks is truly an inspirational
character when you think about
everything that he's been through
and yet he still kept that heroic fire
burning in his heart
in spite of everything although his
public persona may come off as
cocky and a bit indifferent we all know
that on the inside
hawks is a true warrior a true survivor
and a true hero if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more boku
no hero videos right here on the channel
please leave that like to let me know it
only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a lot of our videos even if you
are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
thanks again to tapitune for sponsoring
this video check them out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you